el bono sale por fin del confinamiento
por kobe 19 esto debido a que el estado
de victoria alcanzó la cifra del 70 por
ciento de su población mayor de 16 años
con ambas dosis de la vacuna por eso a
partir de ahora no habrá más toque de
queda nocturno abrirán los restaurantes
los cafés y también los salones de
belleza y se permitirán hasta 10
visitantes en casa y se espera que para
el primer día de noviembre tanto sydney
como melbourne ya hayan alcanzado el 80
por ciento de vacunación por eso a
partir de esa fecha habrá muchas más
libertades y se reanudarán gradualmente
los vuelos internacionales porque cabe
recordar que desde marzo de 2020 cuando
se declaró la pandemia a nivel mundial
pues australia tiene sus fronteras
internacionales cerradas inicialmente se
permitirá el regreso de ciudadanos y
residentes permanentes todos deberán
tener las dos dosis de la vacuna y luego
se permitirá el ingreso de estudiantes
internacionales y también turistas hay
mucha alegría en la comunidad de mi
árbol porque cabe recordar que esta
ciudad pues es la que más pasó días en
confinamiento a lo largo de la pandemia
un total de 262 días acumulados en
confinamiento